on a écouté le témoignage de zoé qui a
rencontré mode le témoignage de cali qui
a rencontré latifah et ces deux
témoignages nous ont interpellés sur
cette difficulté lors deux envois de cv
se confronter à des recruteurs des
patrons qu'ils soient ne répond pas soit
répondent négativement dans les 10%
kitty qui daigne vous faire un retour
alors on a relevé pour vous chez vous à
la maison qui peuvent se retrouver dans
ce cas là des astuces pour rédiger le
meilleur cv pour faire en sorte que son
cv sortent du lot sur cette pile cette
montagne sur les bureaux des recruteurs
ça va s'afficher juste dans l'écran
alors ce sont des recruteurs sur
linkedin qui ont été assez assez sympa
pour partager avec eux dit avec vous dit
astuce alors faire un cv épuré bien sûr
ne pas multiplier les polices on a
tendance pour sortir du lot à faire une
présentation très chiadé à mettre plein
de couleurs plein de styles d'écriture
différent c'est non un truc sobre le
plus simple possible utilisez des verbes
d'action pour mettre en valeur ses
expériences ça c'est très important au
lieu de mettre simplement vendeurs
serveuse m vendeurs de poing accueillir
conseiller mettre en valeur ce que vous
apportez directement aux clients dans
votre métier toujours faire un cv
classique sur une page potentiellement
ajouté un cv original en vidéo par
exemple un format qui peut montrer
d'autres compétences mettre les pointer
les plus intéressants dans la partie
haute du cv toujours adapter son cv au
poste visé évidemment ajouter une
rubrique compétences ça c'est très
important les recruteurs cherchent de
plus en plus la personnalité dans les
gens qu'ils vont embaucher donc ce qui
vous différencie si vous aimez le
violoncelle la peinture la photographie
les dominos je ne sais pas n'hésitez pas
à l'écrire évoqué une ou deux
informations personnelles originales
convertir au format pdf et surtout bien
nommé le document que le recruteur sage
sur ce quoi il clique et qui puisse vous
retrouve effectivement donc cv votre nom
l'intitulé du poste bien reprendre les
mots clés de l'offre d'emploi à laquelle
vous postulez que ce soit cohérent et
encore une fois pour faciliter le
travail du recruteur et vous mettre en
avant sur linkedin qui reste le premier
réseau social pour trouver du travail
c'est le plus adapté